just have a look at it with me if the
next thing that you are asked to do
which I am gonna ask you to do it's fine
the derivative of this theme that at
this present moment you probably look at
this and you're wincing really hard
because you're like gross I don't want
to deal with this the only mechanism we
have to deal with this at the moment is
just expand the whole thing and then
you're gonna get eight terms and you
just go one by one you're gonna do the
ball now doing the differentiation is
not the hard part in this case it's the
expansion you're like the algorithm is
just gross right
but hopefully even throughout the course
of this year you have seen so much of
our mathematical understanding or I
should say the way we advanced through
mathematics is we turn complicated
looking problems in two problems we
already know how to solve easily and
that's exactly what we're going to do
with this okay
so right now this is a function called Y
and this variable over here is X right
so it's a function of X called Y ok I'm
going to rewrite this by introducing a
new variable by convention we call it U
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say
see this x squared plus 1 inside here
right I'm going to replace that inside
part with you with you so I'm gonna let
u equal that right now if I've
introduced this new letter I can rewrite
the original function in a much simpler
form let's do it if u is equal to this
inside part then I can say Y is equal to
not x squared plus 1 I can replace that
with you right and that's been raised to
the power 7 ok now think about this
right we originally had Y is a function
of X now I've written the same function
Y as a function of U
ok so I've changed the variable right
but why is this handy is have a look at
this guy remember I introduced we
introduced Leibniz a notation to say hey
you can have dy/dx you don't have to Y
on anything you like I have something
else here not X's right so instead of
writing dy/dx on the neck
line I can write dy on D you okay now I
know that's weird yeah well different
letter okay but it's exactly the same as
what we did before just I'm looking for
use instead of X's what would you do
with this is just a standard raised to a
power what happens to the seven very
good seven the power comes to be the
coefficient and then there's the U and
the power reduces by one okay so you're
like great that's nice I've got a
derivative but it's not the actual
derivative that I wanted right like this
is all to do with y's and x's so how can
I link this back to my original question
ah now think carefully right think
carefully if you have a look back over
here right see this first line that we
wrote here sorry no first second line
that we wrote it's not Y is a function
of X it's U as a function of X right so
this is a whole new thing that we can
differentiate right if I just hid this
right you would say oh that's just a
regular question I can differentiate
that no problem right but it won't be dy
on DX it's going to be d you on DX
that's what's at the front here so out
of this line I can write do you on DX
can you differentiate this guy what
happens to the x squared 2x what happens
to the +1
it disappears doesn't change the
gradient so I've got a derivative now
now look really carefully eyes up
please look at this carefully I have two
derivatives on the board they're
different derivatives right here's one
and here is the other but hopefully you
can see they are not just separate
they're not just unrelated they're
connected they both have use in them
right in this one the U is on the
denominator here misunder use on the
numerator but what I can do is I can
link them together just like any other
fraction watch this dy on do you times
that's this one here times do you on DX
okay so that's this derivative x that
derivatives for reasons that have become
clear in a second I'm gonna get rid of
all my you
now and place them back with exes so
instead of writing seven year to the six
I'm gonna write seven that so that's
what you is right so there's that ^ six
there's seven you to the six that's my
first three video and then what do I
multiply it by just 2x that's the second
derivative yeah 2x okay now I'm going to
tidy this up in a bridge like there's
not much to do to it honestly but before
I do that have a look at the left-hand
side this is just a pair of remember the
first advantage of this these are just
like they're not identical but they're
just like for our purposes fractions
what do you see happening with these
fractions what's the thing to stand out
to you those Thursday years right
there's one on one there's one on the
top so just like regular fractions I can
actually treat these as things that get
cancelled when they cancel what do you
get left with the dy is on the top the
DX is on the bottom this is the thing I
actually wanted from the beginning right
we can just tidy this up a teeny bit
that - and that 714 the X I suppose
belongs out the front as well and then
you've got this guy the power of six
okay now this is the answer I actually
wanted this is the real derivative the
way I got to it was I had to introduce
this extra function to simplify things
but then once I've got an extra drill
you look at this line here see how I
linked these together it's like a chain
of connected derivatives and that's what
this rule that we've just established is
named after this chain of derivatives
that we have here this thing is called
the chain rule just like when we
established that if you differentiate if
you differentiate X to the power of n
right you can just say that is what's
the rule what happens to the end comes
out the front is the coefficient right
and what's the rest of it Q help me up X
to the N minus 1 very good so we
established this rule not because we
want you to memorize stuff but because
this is so much faster than doing first
principles every time right now this is
a new
rawrr we're not giving it to you so
you've memorized more rules we're doing
it because it's so much faster than
dealing with this thing like how gross
would that be and how error-prone if I
actually had to manually expand this
thing okay so this is the chain rule
right down here if you want to put it in
like a big box it's just a bit of a
weird thing to put in a box you would
say dy on DX this is the actual
derivative that you're interested in
right you can calculate it by working
out a chain of related derivatives and
because we usually use fill out of you
to indicate like this substitution
that's what it looks like okay so let me
see if you can try your hand at doing
this one on your own
consider y equals all right we're gonna
give you this four can you give that one
a go no wait I'm gonna change a little
bit sorry yep can you give that one a go
have a look at it carefully remember
what we did we said that thing looks
gross I don't want to really deal with
it because it looks disgusting but if I
can write it with a substitution let u
equal and I want you to think about what
might be a handy thing to substitute in
there then treat it like a regular
derivative and see where you can go all
right have a think
[Applause]
helm I used a video okay I've had I've
had worse I really have
if you've got something call me or mrs.
Lee's over and we'll have a look
so you just going straight there you
haven't introduced the solution have you
yeah doesn't you equal ba ba ba ba ba
you sort of just done that in the
background having you because I don't
see any I don't see any use here right
which is fine like I think that is the
answer but you've just skipped over it
you just done in your head which is okay
but just it really helped me if you show
me that working especially while we're
still early on in this one yeah mainly
because Gary while you will get to the
point where you can do these in your
head without this substitution we will
give you functions that you cannot
possibly to read your head so we need
you to show that uh yeah no I get it
you're like oh I'm gonna do essentially
you're doing the outside in the inside
which is the way I'm gonna talk about it
but I want you to actually I still want
to see the derivatives working together
that's that thing we're assessing okay
when we differentiate the next square we
do get 2x when we differentiate the one
the derivative of a constant is always
just zero so in fact it's plus zero on
the end there yeah Harrison and it's
become u squared think about that let me
know when you're ready mrs. Luce you
gonna answer I'm gonna connect show
everyone
okay guys real quick cuz you can have
two raced off the Rock Hall briefly have
a look the first thing I'm asking you to
do is introduce a substitution u what
did you choose 3x plus 2 as it's just a
very very broad generalization see that
thing in the brackets the thing in the
brackets is the thing you want to
introduce as a substitution we
colloquially call it the inside function
it's kind of buried deep inside the rest
of the function once you've got this you
know later on you're gonna need the
derivative of this thing do you on DX in
this case what is the you on DX it's
just three isn't it so I'm gonna write
that straight away do you on DX equals
three and I'm gonna tuck it in the back
of my mind then I think about the
original function y in terms of nine
times X's which is how I started but in
terms of use the things that I
introduced so I'm gonna write it as fall
on you cubed because I've replaced three
x plus two and then I'm going to do one
more step and write it in negative index
form we will pick this up again in
period four three five we will pick this
up at some stage later in the day just
to confirm you out the right answer and
see where else we can take this Thanks